[Music]
covid19 has caused a surge in global
unemployment like we've never seen
before
but in the u.s jobs have disappeared
faster than
in any other developed country
and then in may america's unemployment
rate began to rebound
while in other developed nations it
remained relatively stable
the us also creates a ton of jobs
because it's easier to
fire people businesses are more
confident to hire people
so you'd expect the flexible labor
markets to
to move more i suppose in response to
changes in in demand in may and june
the us added about 7.5 million jobs but
the unemployment rate is still at the
highest level since the depression
as the pandemic has put us in uncharted
territory we wanted to know
will american jobs bounce back faster
than the rest of the world
[Music]
it's important to understand what
difference a flexible labor market can
make
in europe there's more of a sense that
the the company has to have a very
strong reason
to be able to fire someone whereas in
the us i think it's much more of a
normal
part of business a flexible labor market
has its pros and cons
and proponents say in normal times it
helps keep unemployment low
by making it easy for people to move
between jobs
just look at the difference in how long
people stay at their jobs in the u.s
versus germany
yeah it's a different mentality in
germany it's not a job for life but the
average
employment tenure is 10 years at a
single company compared with 4.2 i think
it is in the
in the us after the 2008 financial
crisis
the u.s unemployment rate recovered
faster than europe's
which also went through a debt crisis so
it makes sense that a more flexible
labor market would see a bigger jump in
unemployment during a recession
since it's easier for companies to lay
off employees when demand falls
but if you look at what happened at the
start of the pandemic you'll see two
very different outcomes
for two job markets economists deem
flexible
the us saw unemployment rise roughly 11
percentage points from january to april
while japan's unemployment rate grew
half a percentage point
that's where different pandemic
strategies come in
in short the u.s chose to give money
directly to workers while the economy
reboots
while others like japan and europe opted
to subsidize companies and protect
jobs canada and the us i think have been
among the ones that have
seen the biggest jump the main reason i
suppose is because they've
they've tried to protect workers rather
than jobs they haven't
gone for these job furlough schemes in
in
on a grand scale as the europeans
have as part of its first stimulus
package
lawmakers sent americans a twelve
hundred dollar one-time stimulus check
and added six hundred dollars a week to
unemployment benefits
effectively accepting a wave of job
losses
they also funded key industries like
aviation to try and prevent or delay
some layoffs
meanwhile japan's government allocated
nearly 700 billion dollars to business
financing
and enacted a program to subsidize up to
around 140
a day in wages for furloughed employees
the eu has invested roughly 120 billion
dollars in similar short-term work
schemes
since those employees are still on the
books even if they're not working
they're not counted as unemployed that
works well for
those lucky enough to have a permanent
job but
it comes at the cost of very high
unemployment for young people in some
countries
or those on temporary contracts i speak
to people
furlough and um yeah i mean
it's essentially a holiday obviously
there's nervousness there's
concern about the the pandemic but
people are spending their time doing
sports or meeting with friends
it's a very different experience being
you know without work in europe
at the moment than in the u.s but the
question is
how long can it last the labor cost is
only part of
what companies are paying you still have
to pay for the premises and there's
other
fees that you have to pay and you've got
no income so at some point you'll still
have to pull the plug and let those
employees go
that breaking point is going to depend
on how fast economies can recover
the longer the pandemic drags on the
more companies could go bust
erasing jobs that likely won't be
immediately replaced
in june the imf projected the global
economy to grow 5.4
next year but said recovery is still
uncertain
in the next two or three years we'll see
which response was better but
traditionally the us
labor market has been much more dynamic
in kind of reallocating
to growth industries just look at how
the us stock market has outperformed
japan and europe
some big american companies have done
really well throughout the pandemic
and there are high hopes that the
companies that have done well will
decide to create
jobs while europe and japan have kept
unemployment rates relatively stable so
far
they risk supporting jobs that might not
be as valuable by the time the pandemic
ends think aviation or german auto
workers producing parts for engines that
will likely be
phased out will you want to have exactly
the same jobs in place
two years down the line probably not
germany recently allocated 12 billion
dollars to expand its job support
program
until the end of 2021 but the future of
u.s
business support is still unclear as
lawmakers have to regularly assess and
approve stimulus
packages it's just so much uncertainty
about how long this is going to last
the next big debate is going to be about
the exit strategy and how to
how to phase out some of these programs
even if the u.s unemployment rate keeps
falling
the cbo predicts it'll take more than a
decade to reach pre-pandemic levels
while other developed countries haven't
made such long-term projections yet
the ecb forecasts that unemployment in
the eurozone will still be above
pre-pandemic levels in 2022
a full economic recovery from this
pandemic is going to take
years and by the time it's all over we
may be looking at very different labor
markets around the world